Yo-Yo Ma is the world's most renowned
cellist and it's most famous a prodigy
at age four he has globetrotted most of
his life as a virtuoso
soloing with the greatest orchestras on
the grandest stages but you can have no
ear for classical music and still know
the name yo-yo Mao we met under a canopy
of hemlocks and hickories the 67 year
old talked about his latest project
called our common nature
[Music]
cross-country musical Journey visiting
national parks and other outdoor spaces
like New River Gorge in West Virginia
Kentucky's Mammoth Cave and the Grand
Canyon too his goal connecting to the
natural world around us
[Music]